depuis décembre dernier antoine est
soudeur chez framatome un profil
particulièrement recherchées sur ce site
de saint marcel qui recrutent ces
professionnels en externe et les formes
aux spécificités du nucléaire dans cet
atelier par exemple ils sont huit à
apprendre les gestes qu'ils reproduiront
ensuite sur des cuves et des générateurs
de vapeur
déjà il ya beaucoup de débouchés dans la
soudure après avoir la chance d'être
chez framatome et en tant que cqpm
soudeur serra plus mais ouais je pense
qu il ya de l'avenir dans la soudure il
ya du boulot des soudeurs mais aussi des
chaudronniers des usines heures des
contrôleurs ou encore des ingénieurs au
total framatome projette d'embaucher
trois cents personnes en cdi pour 2019
sur les trois sites de saône et loire
une hausse des effectifs que
l'entreprise doit notamment à des
contrats gagnés pour la fabrication d'un
réacteur en angleterre et à une reprise
de la production de composants destinés
au parc nucléaire français nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans un contexte de reprise
d'activité très forte
et pour accompagner cette reprise
d'activité de nos sites de production
nous avons engagé des deux dès l'année
2018 un grand plan de recrutement et de
formation sur des métiers parfois en
tension donc comme on ne trouvait pas
forcément toujours les compétences qui
nous convenait eh bien nous avons mené
en parallèle non seulement une dynamique
de recrutement avec 260 recrutements en
cdi en externe en 2010 8 300 annoncé
pour 2019 la production de réacteurs
pour le royaume-uni et l'inde est à
l'étude
l'entreprise se prépare aussi à
l'éventuel renouvellement du parc
nucléaire français vieillissant des
projets qui permettraient à framatome de
rester le premier employeur privé de
saône et loire